my spouse's spending is crippling our
finances and our marriage each month we
have only about 5 to 600 left after
monthly bills and minimum debt payments
and we only have $1,000 saved I've tried
to speak lovingly to my husband and let
him know how much the overspending
scares me and affects my mental health
I've also had moments of frustration and
have blamed him for financial struggles
which I realize is not a healthy
approach seems all my efforts and
approaches are futile I understand the
Rams principles behind join accounts and
have lived this way for years but at
what point in my marriage do I say
enough and separate myself financially
I'm glad she I'm glad she had the
courage to write is crippling our
finances and our marriage because this
type of behavior tells me there's other
issues in that marriage yeah this guy is
um kind of got the axis of the world
stopped through the top of his head
everything spins around him he's the
most important thing that ever lived I'm
telling you his mama told him that